- Ladies and gentlemen,
The Opposition premiered
last night, and I'm in hour
25 of reviewing our reviews.
So again, these are again
real life press clippings.
We start at the so called
Daily Beast which misquoted us.
We said Alex Jones
is a raging bull,
virile, masculine, feral,
but they said Jones
is a raging bowl,
B-O-W-L.
And you might think
it's just a typo,
but The Beast hyperlinked
to a picture of a bowl.
And it's not just any
bowl, ladies and gentlemen,
it's a salad bowl.
So obviously The Daily Beast
is in the pocket of big kale.
And since we first
discovered this error,
I mean, message, The Daily
Beast has subsequently
taken down the bowl language,
and erased the hyperlink.
Coincidence?
I think not.
Next we go over to the AV Club.
More of an AV cult connected
directly to skull and bones,
and free masons,
and the Beyhive.
And they say, quote, Niccole
Thurman seen whooping
it up as a long black
person at a trump rally
where she's habitually
posed by Trump staffers
right behind the
podium every time
is an analogist, is an analog.
Those conspicuously
few non-white faces
Trump habitually trots out
to refute charges of bigotry.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that was one sentence.
One
long
sentence.
They used the word
habitually twice.
Almost as if this
writer has some kind of,
I don't know, routine using
that word whatever it means.
These are the lies
the main stream media
is trying to tell you and
every single one of them
has since been taken down.
Redacted.
Hidden from your view.
But we at Oppo Radio know
how to take screen shots.
We're screen shooting for you.
Next we move over to this
review from The Chicago Tribune.
Which refers to a fictional
MSNBC host,
Christ Hayes.
Now, my colleague Laura Gray
says that this is a typo,
but ladies and
gentlemen, you and I know
there's no such thing as a typo.
Freud's theory was
that if you put
it down on paper you meant it.
So this is a class example
of the mainstream media
trying to slip its
cultish iconography
into our reviews.
So be on the look out,
ladies and gentlemen.
For other examples of deities
paired with MSNBC hosts.
It starts with Christ Hayes,
but look out for Buddha Maddow.
Or Vishnu Matthews.
When you see those
symbols in your tribunes,
and your heralds,
and your timeses,
that's how you know that
the mainstream media
is trying to brainwash you
with their religious symbols.
Oh, I see how it
coulda been Chris.